from undersea battles to crime-solving
Pokemon November was filled with
exciting glimpses of upcoming movies
here are all the November trailers that
showcase some of the best looking new
films will the merc with a filthy mouth
still bring enough of his trademark
charm in a pg-13 film that's the
experiment 20th Century Fox is running
this December by releasing a cleaned-up
version of Deadpool 2 for Christmas that
should work
the first order of business is to get me
in front of cable so I can pull all the
blood out of his body and fashion his
bones into holiday jewelry although to
be honest since you can't tell what Ryan
Reynolds mouth is doing under that mask
it can't be too hard to dub in some more
family-friendly jokes just look at all
the versions of this scene oh yeah your
bullets they're really fast
well those bullets like super fast
now once upon a Deadpool we'll also
apparently feature some entirely new
scenes featuring Fred Savage back in his
role as the little kid in bed from The
Princess Bride check it out when once
upon a Deadpool hits theaters on
December 12 as the director of The Lord
of the Rings Peter Jackson is a guy who
knows a thing or two about big epic
films and few stories fit that
description better than mortal engines
although he won't be directing Jackson
is producing and co-writing this
dystopian story about massive rolling
cities that eat other cities because
really what else could a giant city eat
tuna fish sandwiches while we've had
plenty of glimpses of mortal engines in
the past months November saw an extended
trailer that focuses more on the crazy
world of the film take a look when
mortal engines premieres on December
14th after becoming the surprise star of
Justice League in 2017 Jason Momoa is
back in the role of Aquaman in a
standalone movie that will see him
fighting to save Atlantis from his
half-brother orme and taking on a swarm
of deep-sea monsters called the trench
oh and Black Manta is in there too it's
clear that Warner Brothers has a lot of
faith in this movie and all signs point
to an outrageously fun big-screen
adventure for DC fans after all the
jokes at his expense
maybe Aquaman will finally get the last
laugh you can take the dive when Aquaman
arrives on December 21st Keanu Reeves
headlines this sci-fi thriller as a
scientist who finds himself in dire
straits after he clones his dead family
how could you do
because I love you
apparently he broke some rules when he
fired up his big old clone oven because
now the government's gunning for him and
his family what's a simple scientist to
do fight back to save his loved ones
again replicas has been a long time
coming it was announced in 2014 and
began production in 2016 making a nearly
five year journey to the big screen
hopefully it was worth the wait
replicas hits theaters on January 11th
2019 M night Shyamalan splicing a lot of
hype and November's minute long TV spot
highlights
Kevin crumbs beast persona and more
scenes from some kind of battle against
the police of course being an M night
Shyamalan film there's no doubt that
glass is going to feature plenty of
twists that aren't being touched on in
the trailers tellingly none of the
trailers show what mr. glass is up to
outside of that psychiatric hospital
that's all the more reason to check it
out when glass breaks into theaters on
January 18th
serenity has equal potential to be
either a harrowing mind-bending thriller
or a whole bunch of crap it's hard to
tell at this point Matthew McConaughey
stars as the captain of a fishing boat
enjoying the quiet island life in the
tropics he's reunited with his
interstellar co-star Anne Hathaway who
asks him to kill her husband from that
launching point the trailer dives into a
world of paranoia and backstabbing with
hints that there's a bigger plot line at
work behind the scenes this home harms a
part of it but nobody knows it serenity
was written and directed by Steven
Knight who previously put out 2013's
lock starring Tom Hardy and wrote the
screenplay for David Cronenberg's
Eastern Promises look for serenity to
drop into theaters on January 25th 2019
right now there are two camps when it
comes to Alita battle angel on one side
people seem to be having a little
trouble dealing with the decision to
make Aaliyah's eyes big and anime like
so what'd he say
I say no it's not art on the other side
you have people who are genuinely
excited to see the beloved manga come to
the big screen ultimately it'll come
down to how well the film handles the
story sure some of the CGI looks a
little goofy and Aleta's relationship
but the boy in the trailer smells a lot
like high school melodrama you were the
most human person I have ever met
fingers crossed that none of that will
drag the film down with both Robert
Rodriguez and James Cameron working
behind the scenes to bring Ali to her
life there's still a chance this could
be one of the surprise hits of 2019 find
out when it lands on February 14th the
future just got a whole lot more
interesting with the release of the
second teaser for captive state like the
first teaser this one showcases a world
in turmoil as humanity tries to win back
its freedom from a ruling class of
extraterrestrials Rise of the Planet of
the Apes director Rupert Wyatt is
helming and co-writing the film with
Ashton Sanders and John Goodman starring
check it out in March 2019 Ryan Reynolds
is set to star in detective Pikachu
providing the weirdly deep voice of
pokemons iconic yellow electric mouse
thing I know you can't understand me but
put down the stapler or I will
electrocute you the story sees Pikachu
teaming up with a young man named Tim
Goodman to find Goodman's father a
detective who went missing since Goodman
is apparently the only human who can
understand what Pikachu is actually
saying they have to work together to
navigate the magical world of adorable
Pokemon critters to solve the case
you got a catch detective Pikachu in
theaters on May 10th 2019 it's been
eight years since Toy Story 3 left buzz
woody and everyone else in the care of
little Bonnie while Andy left for
college it was an ending that was both
heartbreaking and heartwarming and it
made the perfect close to the
relationship between Andy and the
lovable gang of toys until now
Disney Pixar is bringing them back into
our lives in 2019 with Toy Story 4 which
will follow the toys on a new adventure
that hopefully will be just as touching
as the preceding three films the main
voice cast is returning with Tom Hanks
and Tim Allen voicing Woody and Buzz
respectively Hanks has remarked that the
ending of Toy Story 4 is particularly
emotional get ready to weep openly in a
movie theater in June 2019 after months
of anticipation Disney finally released
the first trailer for their upcoming
live-action remake of The Lion King and
it looks exactly like the original film
the teaser mostly focuses on the opening
scene from the 1994 version showing baby
Simba on fried rock as Rafiki anoints
with red baboon juice or in this case
dust another shot the trailer shows is a
sweeping view of a herd of wildebeest
stampeding into a gorge while mufasa's
voice says the Sun will set on my time
here that's clearly some not so subtle
foreshadowing that the 2019 movie will
probably recreate the scene that made
our six year old selves realize that
life was a meaningless void
anyway that new Simba sure does look
cute we just can't wait for the Lion
King to hit theaters in July 2019
[Music]